okay shut up i was pruned before you
even existed i have been waiting for
this moment my entire life
i just need a second to get my head
straight okay sure
what's up everybody carlos here welcome
to et canada's nerd alert we got another
very special edition a loki round table
for the season finale not
series finale and this is a very
exciting stuff uh i've got with me
like i said last time there are two my
favorite people on the planet this i can
i can
honestly say two of my favorite people
in the multiverse
we've got author for comics novels and
video games
sam mags here and pop culture
commentator and walking
talking human comics encyclopedia
jeff jay very excited to have you both
thanks for joining us
thanks for having us
we who remains he will revenge
she's still calling me now creepy
right i like it
in my opinion they gave us like the best
versions
of like the surprises that we wanted
surprises that we were looking for
i want to jump right into it and talk
about the biggest one
the reveal of who's behind the tva he
who remains now this is a very
interesting take on this character
i'm not sure that everybody knows but
you know
he who remains himself is a character in
the comics
the founder of the director of the tv
living at the end of time but
in this version he remains also
something
else jeff jay i know you know about this
i know you're excited to talk about it
so
let's get into it what is this
connection between he who remains
and who we've all been thinking is at
the end of this whole thing kang the
conqueror
well it's interesting you say that
because
he's a variant too he
is a variant we we have stepped in the
middle
and found out the history of the kang
wars the multiversal war was really
the war of kang or nathaniel richards
or iron lad or immortus
or whatever names that man has more
aliases than
your favorite pop star right he
he was telling the truth and lying at
the same time
the fact that there was a whole war but
he and his the rest of his variants
across the multiverse
were the catalyst for me and
it's interesting to me because he who
remains
is still not he who we thought he was
so yes they just opened up a whole bag
of interesting
fascinating lore that they've adapted
in a real uncanny way and just who are
you
i've been dubbed many names by many
people
a ruler a conqueror
he who remains a jerk
the big sort of lean that everyone was
going towards but it's all about kang
it's all about kang this all every all
signs point to kang
and like i said i thought we kind of got
that but we didn't sam can you talk
about what it was like getting this
particular surprise in the episode
i think to your point it did the best
possible job
of giving fans what they were kind of
wanting or hoping for
while also you know to just point kind
of subverting their expectations
by altering the lore a little bit or
being willing to play with it and be
flexible
which i think is really great because a
lot of people who are watching these
shows like
us are big comic book fans we like know
everything about kane the conqueror like
whatever
but like a lot of people watching don't
and so it's cool
that both factions now have something
fresh
whether you kind of knew the source
material or not
i thought this take on the character was
really really great um
and i don't know i kind of i dig the
idea that maybe this is like the
immortus version
of kang like maybe that's this variant
we still don't really
know uh he seems confident he'll be back
i'm sure we will see him over and over
again over the course of phase four we
already know he's going to be in
ant-man and quantomania so
this is not the last we have seen of him
by far i think
something i think is really cool about
this version
of let's say kang or he who remains
whatever
like jeff you said at the beginning he's
a variant also and so for john majors
who gets to play this character
this is like one version of
the character one way to play the
character and like he said we'll be
seeing
kang we think over the course of phase
four so i imagine
this actor will have an opportunity to
play this character or variance of this
character in
many different ways in all the different
incarnations that we see even at the
very very end
of this episode we see that that statue
in the library of the timekeepers the
three statues are replaced with the one
statue
where he's wearing essentially kang's
costume
kang's armor and that in and of itself
gives a different air than the character
that we met at the end of time
right and you know they got the right
actor to do it
this man he was acting as if
he was us watching and
in the the show at the same time like he
could have broke
out some popcorn and he looked like he
was watching like uh reality tv
the way sylvia and loki were arguing
over what to do with him
and from the mannerisms to how in awe he
was
of what he created and how it was
completely
undermining even his expectations his
his facial expressions the the the
surprise and shock you can hear in his
voice
and also the fact that you know he he
was equal parts irreverent as he was
authentic as he was deceitful he admits
what he lies then lies again and admits
it again
you know it's he has a clean slate
jonathan majors does because we haven't
seen kane in live action
at least in this era i don't know if it
happened in the 60s or 70s
but we haven't seen kang so this is the
live action interpretation
of kang and if i had to imagine someone
who's been cooped up
in a office for eons plotting the course
of time and survived the war with
multiple versions of himself that would
be somebody who's like one step
one step off the ledge ready to be gone
but still
is hyped to see the unknown finally
happened for the first time in millennia
on majors in this episode is all of us
as restrictions are lifting
hence ages and ages
of cosmic harmony hence
[Music]
you're welcome in this episode we get
like a couple of
emotional climaxes with loki and
sylvie um there were conversations that
we had earlier about like
their love lives romantic partners that
we don't see
um that have been off screen let's say
but here we get the culmination of
of their conflicts but also their
connection sam what did you think of the
way that these characters came together
at the end of this season i thought it
was really beautiful i love that we
didn't get a pat resolution and one of
my favorite moments
in the finale was the moment where tom
hiddleston just really laid it out
in plain language why aren't we saying
this the same way
because you can't trust
and i can't be trusted the kiss was so
emotional and i had been so hoping for
it
and it was such a great payoff and when
she kicks in through the door i was just
like
in tears about it it was so it was just
it was so satisfying and realistic and i
have to say now too what i like is that
sophie now gets what is essentially my
favorite character arc
ever which is character fixated on
revenge for their whole life gets
revenge
now what now what and you could see in
that last frame with her sitting on the
floor that like
that obviously brought her no closure
like she feels no different
than she did before and so like where
does she go now
apparently she knocked loki into a
different universe so maybe there i
don't know
but yeah it was it got to me it got to
the romantic
in me a little bit jeffy what did you
think about it
i i thought it was awesome and i i love
the fact that it was still
unresolved in the sense that they both
reached
their character arcs of who they were
going to become
but still succumb to their sensibilities
like loki made a complete 180 from who
he was in that point of the timeline
to who he is now so it's almost like the
little kid
who cried wolf and the one time that
he's actually telling the truth
he pays for it or nobody believes it
i just
i just want you to be okay
from her perspective she didn't get a
chance to live a life
her life has been dedicated to
finding this man and ending him because
she was taken from her timeline as a
child
so there's nothing left for her to go
back to and nothing
really to look forward to whereas loki
and he who remains are looking at the
situation
as gods it's not personal it's practical
do what do what's best for the greater
good
as opposed to what's personal for you
um i i do love how this whole season has
played out as an extended
sylvia origin story and i think there's
a lot of possibilities for where she
could go
i don't know if she's going to be
incorporated into any of the big screen
features but like
season two of this show is obviously
gonna focus on her a lot
um the one thing i will say though i
know there's kind of a hot date and some
most popular one
i don't like the two of them
romantically linked together it
it took me a long time to accept that
that's where they were gonna go i kept
kind of thinking they were
like maybe there was something else
maybe those looks
didn't mean that because for me they
read
as le in the earlier episodes they led
as less
um romantic possibilities for each other
and more of as
like little mirrors of each other or
like almost this brother-sister
relationship and that when that moment
happened on momentous
and they really lean into it i was like
i don't know how i feel about this
but here we are but here we are
countless different versions of a very
dangerous person and they're all set on
war we need to prepare
take it easy you're an analyst right
what division are you from
what are you talking about who are you
what's your name moving into the idea of
uh
of a season two of this there's so many
platforms dangling and that's what we
want because we want the possibilities
one
we want to imagine what's going on
we know at the end that loki goes to
this other version of the tva
and they have not met him before they
don't know who he is so maybe they've
never dealt with the idea of loki
variance
whatsoever this is a clear signal that
the multiverse is happening
all these different realities are
branching out um
what are our hopes for season two for
the different characters i'm going to
start
with of course loki himself
jeff what do you think i think loki
loki might end up in prison again to
start the season
because it looked like they didn't know
who he was and if he's on a timeline
where kang
is the the clear-cut known leader of the
tva
then he's either going to have to answer
to kang
or find some way to blend in because it
looked like they were
going to um question him a little bit
more thoroughly
but i could see him either trying to get
back to sylvie or trying to get back to
his
original timeline like it's giving me
big sliders vibes
if you remember that show sliders yeah
huge
sliders vibes right now that he's going
to be going from multiverse to
multiverse
to find whatever the truth is it's funny
you
you thought sliders i immediately
thought quantum leap as well
it was just like look you drop it into
some difference right generally
yeah totally and uh
i i have to agree with you i think maybe
he
will feel betrayed enough by sophie at
this point
or rejected enough by sophie that
she might not be his goal anymore
but i can see him trying to get back to
save his brother
and his reality which ironically is
exactly what kang
said would happen and which is what
started like the multiverse wars because
you prioritize your reality over all
others
and so i feel like loki is going to kind
of become an unwitting participant
in like the very thing that he wanted to
stop
in the first place because time travel
is messy and there is no real answer
um i'm interested in this idea that
sylvie who over the course of the season
said she was like don't call me a loki
don't call me a loki
um her name is a clear nod to a to a
version of the enchantress
she has powers where she can enchant
people do we think in season two that
this is where we're gonna see her
actually just become the enchantress
like is this the enchantresses
introduction into the mcu
i definitely think so i think so i
thought maybe they weren't going that
way at first but there's so much
to connect her to that now that it feels
almost inevitable
and i think her moment at the end of
this episode where she said
i'm not you like that was the end of her
being a loki
and was maybe the start of her being
enchantress i don't know
that's how i would write it yeah i can i
can see that for sure
i'm wondering how she gets out of
the end of time and where she goes next
because you know she she she completed
her quest
and he remained set right come on
no you can't get to the end until you've
been changed by the journey this
stuff it needs to happen
to get us all in the in the right
mindset
to finish the quest i feel like that's
almost like a meta dialogue for
everybody who wants these fairies
to be true and wants to just get to the
end and find out he's like you haven't
even been transformed yet
walk the path before you get to the
destination so i thought that was so
funny when he was like yeah we kind of
already know but it's the journey
that's important i was like you're
talking to me right
right exactly
[Music]
for all time
always the biggest disappointment
kind of my mephisto moment for this
whole season the series
the jet ski guys
i thought for sure somehow
we were gonna get mobius on some
like i don't know how it was gonna work
was it gonna drop from the sky was it
gonna be there in the void
nothing i don't know there's always a
season two moment
there's gonna be more build up to the
jet ski now
i think i think it'll be a big payoff i
agree i mean it wasn't it wasn't perfect
i think there were things that were
missing for me
um i wish loki prime our loki
had been a bit more of an active
protagonist he felt kind of passive
in the series as a whole kind of being
shifted along by other people first by
mobius and then by sophie and even in
the end it wasn't
loki's choice to establish the
multiverse it was sophie's choice
so which is a different thing entirely
but in this context
you know what i mean uh but you know
nothing that happened in the series was
too much like because loki things kind
of happened
to loki and so i'm really hoping in
season two that we get to see
a lot more like uh forward action pushed
by our
true protagonist um however if they're
basically trying to set up that loki is
about silly
then that doesn't attract like what take
back and take off everything i just said
because she
pushes almost all of the action of the
show so if that
is the context in which we're supposed
to interpret it then dead on
this jet ski might be the biggest
storyline
that goes throughout however many things
and it's not until the series finale
that we
that's what i think it's called the jet
ski right i would love that
like how we had the cameo of the thanos
copter in the void
the finale of season two is kang riding
in on a jet ski and mobius having to
take it from him
eddie that's how we get
so in i'm so in
i also have to say i'm super stoked
about jeff you brought this up in like
the very first thing you said about king
which is that he's descended from reed
richards and sue storm
uh and knowing what we know as big dorks
about the fact that marvel now has
access to
the fantastic four to put them in the
mcu
uh and dr doom has a lot of connections
to kang
silver surfer um you know i
i'm so interested to see how they end up
playing into things and i
i'm really interested in seeing what
happens to ravana because she disappears
halfway through this episode
you know her connection with kang is
very strong they're like together
he betrays her the grandmaster ends up
telling her that he betrayed her
because the grandmaster is like a drama
queen like there's just so much good
stuff here
that i can't wait to see what they do
with it and how they play with it
so many ways so many so many timelines
that they can go across
to do it with with having basically all
of their properties back
it's just it just the possibilities are
endless and it also leaves
open my theory that the next multiversal
war
is going to be secret wars
into kang that connection to doom
it yeah it can really come across
because i personally think the only way
you can bring
mutants into this whole uh uh diaspora
of of uh um property
is through the multiverse theory yeah
there's no way magneto and
charles xavier were hanging out on the
island when all of this was going on
and no one in the population was
discovered to be a mutant and there
wasn't any type of
discoveries that that would be kind of
shoehorning it a little bit but i think
this is
this is giving them a creative way to
introduce
mutants into the mcu i agree and it's
why i actually think ralph loehner from
one division
evan peters was actually multiversal
quicksilver
and i think we're still gonna learn that
at one time because it's just it's too
it's too good uh that's too much
otherwise
you're ralph boner
boner we did see very recently that hugh
jackman and kevin feige were hanging out
and who is the one character that
everyone knows and loves
but a version of him that also can go
between dimensions between worlds and
that's
old man logan so an interesting way to
bring hugh jackman back
and to both of your like points that
theory
of bringing mutants in unless they are
just oncol right now
hanging out on the sidelines who knows i
would be it looks amazing
it's cool it's disgusting sam jeff
i love these talks this is so much fun
um
and when we come around to season two
hopefully we can do this again
and of course i'm proud of this monday
with et canada you can see more of our
videos right here
on youtube make sure you subscribe we
got a lot of nerd alert videos for
things like this
for things that you love and also not so
nerdy videos as well a big thanks again
to jeff j
and sam mags and we'll see you guys next
time